what's going on everybody today I'm
going to show you how to perform in all
keys lost for a newer Ford this is a
2018 Ford F-150 says smart key I'm going
to show you how to do the all keys lost
on the autel
im508 now I'm going to go ahead and get
to my Ford and load my vehicle info one
thing I would strongly recommend
is do not do all keys lost unless you
absolutely have to uh you can even if
you've lost all the keys you can just do
add a key uh the reason I'm doing this
is we've u reflashed a computer did a
parameter reset so we're going to go
ahead and do the all keys lost to
recognize the keys I'm adding
three one right here one right here and
a second here or a third here uh other
thing you want to take note of is where
the learning slot is for the smart key
on this vehicle we are looking at our
cup holder
you'll remove the little grommet there
and you'll see a little insert for the
key to go we can go ahead and take one
key place it in there like so and we'll
get started with our ignition on we're
going to go ahead and automatically read
the
VIN we'll select smart key
from here I'm going to go to control
unit keyless system key
learning now I'm going to go ahead and
select all smart Keys lost we will need
internet and it's telling us it's normal
for the instrument cluster to black out
and that it's going to delete the keys
so once we know that that's all going to
happen we'll select
yes and we'll see what entails sometimes
you get a 10 minute wait for security
access we do not have an active alarm so
we'll select
no so now what we're having here is the
nav screen has went out our cluster has
shut off that is completely normal
usually when I do this that it works but
what I'm going to do is go ahead and
pause the video until we get to our next
screen just so it doesn't take up 10
minutes of uh the same screen here so uh
I'll be back once it go ahead once it
configures a system and and we'll move
on okay we're about 3 or 4 minutes in
our nav screen has come back our gauge
cluster is on got some warning lights
see if I can show you here between the
steering wheel Hill start not assist
that stuff's normal to see it's just a
lack of communication with the
BCM and those lights will go away so
what it's saying here is we're going to
have to have two keys for clearing Keys
going to go ahead and hit yes
that's how many keys we have learned to
the vehicle it's going to erase
them now we have zero keys so we've got
our keys still in the learning
pocket insert key to be
learned we're going to hit okay and
we'll hear the door lock cycle
so there's our first
one go ahead and put that away going to
take our second
one hit
yes new key is in the
slot all right so we've got our second
key in the car should be good to to
start let's go ahead and add this third
key if I'm not mistaken this key has a
dead battery so there's a chance we
might have to open it up for it to get
some signal there I've had that happen a
lot so we'll go to the third one through
our
menus we'll see if it fails on this one
nope all right there we have it we've
got three keys learn to the vehicle
now see if we can get that lock cycling
try all
three and we're going to go ahead and
hit no on the autel let it close
out let's see if she
starts and you'll notice those error
lights about the hill assist have went
away so
there you have it guys that's how you do
an all keys lost with your autel im508
on the new or Fords it's a 2018 F-150
hope that helps thanks for your time